what would you actually be like to write
a VCS game I wish I'd never started now
we've done some interesting vintage game
videos with Matt Phillips on the Sega
Megadrive Tanglewood similar in some
ways different in others obviously he
was using the original hardware and
software to try and develop redo get on
old PC these scuzzy car the connection
things to do it I've gone for a
different approach so I'm writing it in
6502 assembler which is the same with
the CPU users or well the variant of it
will look at the hardware more detailed
in another computer file but I'm writing
in there and I'm emulating it using main
to generate - players I'm writing the
software
compiling it using a modern machines
over all the nice friendly tools then
I've read a couple of tools to generate
the ROM image which we can then feed
into MAME to generate things main aims
to emulate the electronics very low
level so it tries to be exactly as
possibly a simulation which is good in
this case I don't have an actual console
but I do have Krissy of the wonders of
the internet a copy of the circuit
diagram and it's not that complicated
machine you've got the 6507 CPU as far
as the program is concerned it's a 6502
CPU the same as a file in the commodore
64 in the BBC micro and then tendo
various different things at the time the
special thing about the 6507 is that it
had a slightly reduced number of pins so
he didn't have the full 16-bit address
bus it's only got 13 bits available
which means you have got quite so much
memory and so on in terms of actually
writing the software for it programs
more that's the same you've also got the
6 532 which is again as a standard chip
which provides some IO and it also
provides all the RAM for the system
which is 128 bytes yes
1 - 8 bytes not kilobytes not megabytes
not gigabytes 128 bytes that's
challenging to code for then where do
you start with a thing like that well so
the first thing you have to remember is
that actually that's not the only memory
you've got so that's your RAM that's
where you can store so that's pretty
story variables and you can manipulate
and store data there what you've also
got is the game cartridge itself which
is in fact
rom chip which I have sitting yeah these
are bigger than you Louisa 32k EEPROM
chips
you only get a 4k allocated on the 2600
so you've got to write your game or your
program for the 2600 to run in 4k of
memory to store the code but you can't
change that so all your code your
graphics your data house sounds have to
be stored in that 4k you can't change it
there are ways that came later where you
can sort of Bank switch to actually have
more storage but you have to program
that and build the hardware yourself on
the base machine the base cartridge
you've got 4k of ROM which you can't
change and 128 bytes of memory which you
can use to store things now that might
sound not too bad and you think well ok
hold the write something like pong which
is what sort of games it was originally
designed for I need to store the
position about 1 back to the position of
the ball and that's probably three but
the other thing you have to remember is
that when you call subroutines and
things in a machine Co program you need
space to store where you got to return
to we looked at this in a previous video
that normally goes on the stack and
you've also got to fit that stack on the
thing and the way the 6502 stack works
is it starts counting down from one FF
in hex down and so that meets up with
your variables coming from 80 or so in
hex and they sort of meet in the middle
so you've not actually got that much
space you have to keep track of things
fairly carefully so that's the sort of
standard stuff the thing that makes the
2600 the 2600 is it's got this chip in
the middle of the TI a the television
interface adapter and that's what
generates the graphics that you see and
the sound that you hear on screen when
playing the game was the system runs the
software on the 6502 with the RAM in
there from the program in the cartridge
and you have to drive the TI a chip to
generate the display on screen simple
you might think but this is not a
computer like say a BBC micro or c64
where you've actually got a display
where you can write characters into or
you can set pixels on and off now this
is very much a low-level thing you have
to program basically the whole video
signal system that you would see on your
screen almost by half
and including turning the
synchronization signals on that start
the spewing in the right place and make
sure it actually looks right if you get
that wrong
you won't produce a valid video signal
that your TV would recognize and so the
display would go all skew if and worst
case scenario it wouldn't be impossible
to make the TV catch fire if you got it
really wrong where they would actually
catch fire probably not but you could
certainly do some nasty things if you
got it wrong so the other thing just
like Matt was saying with the Sega is
that the cartridge is everything when
you put the cartridge in the CPU is
connected directly to it and it starts
to executing the code from the cartridge
so there's no operating system there so
you have to set everything up yourself
so the first thing you have to do on the
program is literally zero the memory
turn off the interrupts and so on and
just make sure everything is set up and
then you have to go into what was often
called the kernel of the 2600 and start
programming it to display things so if I
get the programmers manual which again
from the one that's on the internet you
can get the copy of the ti a chip or
stellar I think it's sometimes referred
to in the 2600 will generate the
horizontal sync everything else you're
responsible for so it's generating one
line of the image and then it will start
the next line if you want anything to
appear in there you have to program that
chip to generate that pattern that you
want to expect and when you get to the
next line you have to generate the bits
on the next thing until you build it up
to build up the whole image and you sort
of scan down the thing and if you look
at a CRT in slow motion you will see it
scanning down building up the image bit
by bit and then building it up by bit
something like ask y'all isn't it you
know you go along you put what you want
in the right place and you press a
carriage return and you carry on and
yeah I mean that's one way of thinking
about it filling up the whole screen 50
times a second and you have to generate
everything within those three hundred
twelve and a half lines to generate the
images again pal speak 625 lines on the
screen 50 fields of half a frame and so
I'm going watch the video on interlacing
or we can assume it's got 312 lines that
we scan and if you look at this diagram
then you have to make sure that a
vertical sync happens for three scan
lines and then you have a black bit
which is basically telling the screen to
make sure the thing is drawn is it
refresh
back up to the top left of the screen
start drawing things again and then you
start drawing your picture and you've
got a little bit of space while the sync
happens and you have to set all the day
to up to draw the first line go back to
the next line start drawing the second
line and so all by hand there's no
support here other than you can say to
the TI a wait for the horizontal sync
and it was pause the CPUs execution
until that happens and then start
executing the program again so you have
to write your code to do this literally
drawing the screen line by line you then
have 30 lines which you won't see on the
TV because they're off the bottom of the
picture and then you start the vertical
sync again you have to do this
continuously because if you stop you
don't generate a proper television
program we tell the chip to dastar
generating the vertical sync signal and
you do this by writing for a particular
memory location within that chip is
mapped in as we talked about in the past
we then wait for three of the lines so
we've a loop of three and we wait for
the horizontal thing to happen and camp
three and then we turn it off and then
we start drawing the vertical bank blank
area in the same way we've set a
different location we wait 45 or so
lines in apparel image to do that and
then we can actually start drawing our
graphics should make it so we start the
emulator for the first 128 lines or so
we're literally just changing the color
of the background on every line in the
screen and then for the rest of the
screen I've just filled it with white
and again I'm counting the number of
lines and then we stop and we start
drawing this all again so we have to
code that in the thing when programming
the 2600 the phrase that people used was
racing the beam because if your program
got too long it would get out of sync
with the beam and it would delay things
as it appear at a different point so
this mean that store a variable in the
wrong place would actually affect the
graphics yeah so if you did particularly
think so storing your variables will
take a constant amount of time but for
example if you do make a decision so you
can pair somewhat then you branch will
you don't branch they'll take different
amounts of time or your code paths will
have different lengths and so in one way
you might delay things to not happen at
the right point there's two things you
could do to sort of get out of that
firstly you've got the vertical
during that period nothing's being
displayed so you can do all sorts of
calculations there and not have to worry
about it you can sort of work out on
average how many lines this bit of codes
going to take because you know how long
each clock cycle is compared to the
video signal so you saw you've got your
video signal going and your CPUs going
and you need to keep track of how those
things are until you get to the point
where you think okay I've done I now got
30 lines left of the vertical blank I
feel just wait for 30 lines and so
you're a slave to the display absolutely
yeah if you if you've got things out of
sync the display would have whatever
data was in there what was on the
previous line would continue displaying
it and then you'd get to that point and
you could do things now the tih of the
stellar chip did have some things to
help you you had a background which was
just a color which is the basing it
displayed and then you could display on
top of that various things so there's
something called the play field which
was 40 bits of graphics you could
program 20 bits of them which would be
displayed from the left half to the
middle of the screen and then it would
either repeat them or reflect them over
the other side remember the chip was
designed to sort of create the sort of
pong or tank battle games that were
popular in the late 70s and everything
else was people abusing the system that
provides to create more and more
impressive games so you had the sort of
play fields and if we turn this code
back on we can start drawing things into
the play field so I'm going to set the
first four pixels to be on I'm going to
set the second eighth pixel set of eight
pixels to be an oscillating path and the
next set of eight pixels to be a
different oscillating pattern and then
I'll reflect it or not reflecting it
depending on which line I am on so if we
turn that on we get a slightly different
pattern displayed on screen so silver
that colored bars as before but now
we're getting these white lines or gaps
where we've turned on the play field so
it's like over the top of it is it yeah
so we've got four bits here notice how
big these bits take up they're sort of
40 bits across the whole thing on this
we're either reflecting it or we're not
so we get a slightly different pattern
appearing there basically you've got the
background colour then the play field
for that line drawn on top of that
you've also got a ball would be drawn I
think of the pong games being being
being being being you can have a player
1 and player 2 and in each of them could
have a missile that can be fine and they
appear on that line and you can set them
to be different widths and sizes based
on the bits patterns you can draw you
can sort of create the different
graphics I decided okay can I draw the
computer file logo on a 2600 can I write
the code to do that so I set things up
and I have a slightly more complicated
program here I've got about halfway
through it so we'll sort of talk about
how this works and then we'll you know
another episode will actually see if we
get this running on real Hardware see
where I'm actually generating a proper
sync signal probably not looking at the
code and see whether it actually
finished off drawing it so I'm just
using play field graphics here and so on
so what I'm going to do if it's also the
sky color sort of cyan blue eat at color
I'm gonna have a flashing different
color ground and then I'm going to draw
the computer file sort of logo and if
you run it we've got the graphics being
drawn and this is the polettis of the
first one I have to set the play field
up for eight lines or so in this
position
the language once set up to draw it in
this position and so on I'm changing the
values that we're putting in there each
time interesting if you look here it
looks like my a bit late changing the
background color and so we get a few
pixels of blue being displayed before we
get the psychedelia effect at the bottom
is almost certainly that my codes being
slightly delayed in drawing that you're
drawing the left-hand side of the screen
and then you're using a flag that
mirrors it yeah I am actually shooting
does that mean that the middle bit is
actually gonna be quite difficult to
drool yeah so there's two possible ways
I could do it I could possibly do some
of it in terms of the playfield graphics
so things like if I position things in
the right place the top bar and the
bottom bar see I could possibly do the
playfield graphics well try this out
when I've actually got a real VCS or
real 2600 is one on the way from eBay
and we'll see if we can get this to
actually draw the full logo so my
current thoughts are I could practice
drill the top bit and the bottom bit
using the playfield graphics and
position them so I actually just said a
couple of pixels here get them
selected that appear in the right place
and then perhaps abuse the balls or the
missiles and so on to actually really
racing the beam draw this side of the
things the other thing I could possibly
do if I was clever is update the
playfield graphics after it's displayed
here and count the cycles of the CPU
going to change what's displayed here by
the time it gets there and sort of draw
using the playfield graphics will have a
bit of a experiment we'll try it on real
hard and we'll see what actually works
but yeah definitely kudos to the real
people who actually spend ages working
how to create games like pac-man and so
on their skills are pretty impressive
having spent some time and because it's
also worth remembering that you didn't
just have to do this on the 26th even
even on something like the ST or the
Amiga people were using similar tricks
racing the beam across to change the
sets with the either the sprite harder
on the Amiga or the display on the
pallets and things on the st2 great
graphics which was technically beyond
what the hardware should have been
capable of producing but of course
people had found tricks to do things so
for example on the Amiga you had eight
sprites that you could display on scoot
on a single line but of course if once
it finishes blowing one you could sort
of move that to the other side of the
screen before it got there and actually
get things happening in the right place
so yeah
you have to count your cycles
so sometimes he fought please wood dies
he often would make backup copies let's
try this one sounds more hopeful and so
there was this game called Lander